Kevin Kelly asks besides the the
marshmallow test
are there other lessons for long-term
thinking for five-year-olds or people
that act like five-year-olds well I do
think this idea of of creating buffers
to our impulses is important and that
also by the way worked for the it was
another tactic that worked for the
doctors prescribing antibiotics which
was to create a little pop up in the
electronic health record when they're
about to prescribe the antibiotic that
says what's there basically what's your
reason for prescribing this antibiotic
to this patient it's just a simple
question like and if you don't want to
answer it you have to check no
justification given and then that goes
in the permanent record so could you use
that for a five-year-old I think you
know people do you I mean actually I
think in some ways people parents I'm
not a parent but I observe parents using
some of these tactics may be better than
then the rest of us because they're
trying to get their kids right to think
beyond their impulses and then we sort
of forget that we are as adults also
very governed by it by our impulses and
that our technological tools reinforce
that often they don't have to I think
there are ways that we could use our
technology to actually help us how many
times we look at our phones today yeah
and and then yeah and I think the way
they engineer right the the engineering
around Facebook Likes and tweets right
like it's it's made to reinforce the
availability bias which is basically
right like or it does reinforce the
availability of what we see is what we
think is the most important so we're
constantly seeking that that same
reinforcement that same sort of sense of
satisfaction in the more in the moment
and we think that that's actually what's
important when perhaps what's really
important is not that not what's getting
retweeted but you know the erosion of
the federal court system
or democracy itself